I used to be somebody who saved lives
now I'm just very out and make number
three five six to hear this that you are
to help someone that's a greater pipe
surprise huh
rise above that fear
[Music]
everybody we got new flash footage for
next week and we finally have Mon L in a
comic book
accurate valor costume so let's break it
down and there is a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter just be subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I think it was
right before the flash episode 10 aired
last night my timeline started blowing
up with non flash stuff like is this for
real so I had to check what was going on
and then he to release this midseason
preview for all the CW shows and in it
not only was ma Nell wearing the costume
he was descending as if he had been
blind but remember he has the Legion
ring so that's how he flies on the TV
show they've been a couple different
versions of the character depending on
which rider is on the title and which
error the comics you're in but during
the New Krypton arc the reason why he
became such a big deal and a protector
of the city in addition to the other
heroes was because Superman had gone
back to New Krypton to live as a
Kryptonian for a little while so it was
a very different story arc but way back
in the classic comics it was Mon L in
the Legion of super-heroes like we've
done Superboy in the Legion of
super-heroes they've done Supergirl in
the Legion of super-heroes
it pretty much every turn there is at
least one member of the Superman family
of characters that is paired with the
Legion so we finally got Mon L in the
comic book costume because when they
debuted his first look everyone's like
wait a minute is this it is this what's
going on it was the same thing with
Brainiac and then after the episode of
Supergirl people were like well
brainiacs awesome you know still hoping
that he changes his look just a little
bit but then this dropped and people
like wiped their foreheads collectively
they oh thank god finally a comic book
costume so that'll probably debut in the
next couple of episodes but I don't
think the Legion is gonna be here for
the entire rest of the season on
Supergirl I think they're leaving around
episode 15 or something like that but
obviously getting into the flash footage
we have Barry inside iron Heights there
been a couple different iron Heights
comic book runs if you've been reading
the rebirth comics right now he's
working in iron Heights he's not
actually a prisoner there way back
during the Tri
the flash run he was detained like you
see him on this comic book cover that
I've been posting for the last couple of
weeks like all hurled up in the fetal
position looking like he's gonna cry
himself to sleep because he's so bummed
out but even though they're doing this
parallel art like his father was stuck
in prison wrongfully accused of the
murder of his mother I don't think that
Barry is gonna spend the rest of the
season in jail that he's using this to
show you what's going on inside iron
Heights
and do some of that comic-book trial of
the flash run you may have detected the
creepy warden who said get comfortable
he might look familiar he is a comic
book character like he's a pretty big
[ __ ] in the comics so I'm guessing
it's gonna be the same deal on the TV
show he's not an evil or a super corrupt
person like the warden from Shawshank
but there is going to be a little bit of
Shawshank going on here where he's not
the nicest person in the world it's the
same thing in the comics but that's
mostly because he rules the prison with
an iron fist to make as many prison puns
as possible iron Heights
iron fist now he's not on the metahuman
wing and that's where all of DeVos
Mehta's that they've captured are so I'm
wondering if we're gonna run into any of
them because I don't know that they're
allowed to mingle with anybody in
gen-pop but remember Barry's in his
father cell his father was in iron
Heights for 10 plus years so we'll see
who else knew his father and there but
there aren't too many big comic book
things relative to his father from the
comics like he just he's in prison he
gets out of prison that's about it
usually when the flash is at iron
Heights he's either interrogating rogues
or people that he's captured he's not
interacting with people that used to
know his father there are two really big
iron Heights runs not including the
rebirth one that's happening right now
the original one is called flash iron
Heights it was written by Geoff Johns it
involves this big murmur plot that I
don't think that they're gonna be doing
on the TV show the other one was right
after the thinker arc also a Jeff Jones
story but it involved this big gorilla
City episode where they invaded and they
kind of did that during season three so
I don't expect them to do any of that
stuff either but they might do sort of a
rogue's Prison Break situation
eventually this season - especially
because we have the 12 metas that the
thinker's collecting in addition to all
the other metas that Barry's helped lock
up over the last couple of years
as the flash and as Barry Allen CSI so
it'll be fun to see him mingle with some
of the people that he put in prison like
aw remember you testified at my court
case you helped them lock me away but
for those of you asking he still has his
flash powers but like in the trailer
they trip him in the prison yard he has
to try to live without actually using
them just to prevent any crazy
situations from happening it would be
really hard to explain how inmate Barry
Allen has the powers of the flash
without outing himself to the world but
if you're not reading the flash comics
right now we're actually getting ready
for a flash war there's an iron Heights
run that they're doing in god speeds
part of that everybody always asked when
god speeds coming back he's in the
comics right now they just brought him
back so I will do flash war videos
that'll start at the end of this month
but it'll be a little bit different from
the normal TV show videos but the really
funny thing about the trickster now this
is the axil trickster remember he is the
son of the mark hamill trickster the
original version of the character in the
comics
the real reason I tracked you down and
groomed you to be the best you could
possibly be Axl I have your father
best use of mark hamill ever and I don't
know that mark hamill is gonna be
featured anywhere in this episode just
because they've been on the last Jedi
press tour for like the last six months
so I don't think that he was available
this year to film an episode like when
he did the episode during season 3 that
was because rogue 1 was happening so
like he did have a couple free days so
maybe he'll come back during season 5 or
if he shows up maybe it'll be later this
season but usually him coming back as a
question of his availability based on
Star Wars stuff because he's probably
coming back for episode 9 and they'll be
filming that relatively soon too but the
big easter egg here
elongated knight rises' Dark Knight
Rises just a big joke on that he kind of
had that arc when he was telling Joe not
to do the same thing that he did in last
week's episode like yeah you can plant
this evidence and he tells him this big
long story basically what happened to
him after he got kicked off the force
and how he wound up hating himself and
you realize eventually that you did the
wrong thing but I think people are
starting to come around on his character
you guys can let me know what do you
think of elongated man now versus at the
beginning of the season because he
started out as kind of a douche because
even the president of the network was
criticizing that so it was a bit over
the top but I think they course-correct
it on that relatively quickly but the
problem is is that usually when that
happens you don't see those episodes
that they're filming until months later
like just to give you an idea right
before they went on break they were
filming episode 14 that's how far ahead
they are in terms of filming episodes
and when we're actually seeing them
congratulations to the winner from my
episode 10 video nico martinez please
private message beat so i can get your
contact details on us the winner from
this video when i post new DC my black
lightning episode one video will post
next that should be up in the next
couple of hours but click here for my
episode 10 video and easter eggs and
click here for a brand new Deadpool
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight